nous sommes dans le terminal de
l'aéroport d'anchorage magnitude 7
un séisme très puissant mais loin sous
la terre 40 km suffisant pour qu à la
surface une voiture et son conducteur
coincé comme sur un îlot au milieu d'une
route éventrée quelques minutes plus
tard les secours ont pu le mettre en
sécurité partout les mêmes scènes de
panique
ici un élève avec un bouclier dérisoire
sur le dos et dans cette salle
d'audience
au plus fort de la secousse le plafond
commence à s'effondrer
une femme et 700 fuir puis se ravise se
cache sous un bureau comme ses collègues
une autre plus éloigné de l'épicentre
mais tout aussi secoué après ça j'ai pas
vous
il y aura au moins une quinzaine de
répliques
la station de télévision katie vielles a
réussi à émettre sur internet
ces bureaux sont dévastés
john thompson et journalistes des
séismes il en a déjà vécu mais celui ci
c'était vraiment différent très brutale
et le son on aurait dit un coup de
tonnerre
il fait le tour de la station pour
constater les dégâts
constatait que personne ne se fait
piéger et il fait même un peu d'esprit
il était 8h30 donc il y avait pas encore
foule ici d'ailleurs il ya des gens
sensés être ici à cette heure-là qu'il
n'était pas suffisant et il n'était pas
prêt d'arriver
les routes autour de la ville la plus
peuplée d'alaska ont été vite paralysé
l'alaska est régulièrement frappée par
des séismes c'est une zone à risque fait
partie du quotidien
on a des petites secousses chaque jour
comme ce qu'elle a vécu
d ordinaire et le quotidien pour katie
vielles aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer de
reconstruire son plateau queen informer
les alaskien ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal